funeral services for two jesuit priests
who were killed in northern mexico last
week
members of the indigenous raramudi
community performed a ritual dance to
honor the two priests joaquin mora and
javier campos who were killed during an
alleged encounter with a wanted drug
trafficker
he is a martyr to me because whenever i
talked to him he said that his life was
a eureka municipality and that he would
give his life for the communities and he
gave his life
the killing of the priests sent shock
waves across mexico and frustrations are
growing over worsening violence
as are criticisms of the mexican
government's failure to curb homicides
we continue to demand justice that the
federal public security policy be
changed because this is not working no
matter how much the authorities say that
it is working nothing is going to change
violence in mexico is at its highest
point in decades
statistics suggests that nearly 100
people are murdered in the country every
day the catholic church says mexico is
going through a historic wave of
violence
even pope francis has expressed deep
concerns over the crisis
[Music]
so many killings in mexico i'm close
with my affection and prayers to the
catholic community that's been afflicted
by this tragedy once again i repeat
violence does not resolve problems but
creates unnecessary suffering
[Music]
mexico's president andres manuel lopez
obrador condemned the killing of the two
priests but the president has also drawn
criticism after being asked about the
growing public outcry over his national
security policy
we're not going to modify our strategy
we maintain that human beings are not
evil by nature that is the circumstances
that lead some to take the path of
anti-social behavior
following the deaths of the priests in
the state of chihuahua catholic bishops
in mexico have called on the mexican
government to host a national dialogue
with the goal of taking concrete actions
to build a path toward
peace manuel rapalo al jazeera